hey guys my name is Jess it is Tuesday
and this is that GameSpot news show
which we make every single day of the
week to catch up with those be sure to
subscribe so now here's what's going on
[Music]
first up Sega has announced a bayonetta
for PC and you can trust again as it
turns out that April Fool's joke which
brought Bayonetta to steam as an 8-bit
version helps and water after all well
it's not an 8-bit obviously but it is
classic Bayonetta originally released
for Xbox 360 and ps3 on your PC so get
ready to boot it up try the keyboard and
mouse realize that's probably garbage
plug in the controller and enjoy your PC
edition of Bayonetta in all seriousness
the release is going to support 4k and
allow you to control graphics options
like texture quality and anti-aliasing
just like you can with all your other PC
games HDR can also be enabled and the
game will run at 60 frames per second if
you're sure this is your jam Sega's
giving everyone who buys Bayonetta on PC
before April 25 a free upgrade to the
digital deluxe edition this version
includes a soundtrack sampler a digital
art book wallpapers and avatars if you'd
really rather see it first you can watch
the game running at max settings on PC
on our youtube channel if yesterday's
news about how long uncharted the last
legacy might be picked your interest
you'll be happy to hear that today's
news has delivered a release date and
the price the standalone DLC will come
to PlayStation 4 on August 22nd in North
America for 40 of your dollars there's
also a brand new trailer featuring
Nadine and Chloe exploring on a
riverboat unveiling ancient secrets and
oh so very much Claudia black goodness
there's her pre-order The Lost Legacy at
set and participating retailers can also
get their hands on a free digital copy
of jak and daxter the precursor trilogy
on ps4 if however you preorder on the
PlayStation Store you'll get a bonus
last legacy ps4 theme which let's be
honest I already won good news for Xbox
fans today at call of duty black ops 2
has finally been added to the
backwards-compatibility catalog Major
Nelson took to Twitter today to confirm
that the most requested Xbox 360 game
it's been added to the service black ops
2 is actually a pretty interesting entry
in the annual shooter franchise several
missions feature choices some of which
aren't always obvious that affect how
the game's story plays out if you
already own black ops 2 it should show
up automatically in your Xbox one game
library otherwise you can grab it right
now on the Xbox Marketplace for 25 bucks
if you're concerned about entering the
series too late not to worry as black
ops 1 Call of Duty 2 3 end well the war
are also all available via Xbox one
backwards compatibility that is
everything I've got for you today do let
me know what you cared about down in
that comment section and I'll see you
again tomorrow